hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for April 2nd 2018 what's going on how
welcome to April everybody oh you didn't
think you'd make it did you well the
goddamn snow just kept rolling out of
the [ __ ] sky and all these [ __ ]
liberal concerts talking about global
warming oh yeah I'll [ __ ] cool you
off with my [ __ ] toes you [ __ ]
global warming a lot of people who
[ __ ] when it snows in the winter
people just go to global warming I don't
know Belt don't try to be a scientist
okay you've tried to be a lot of things
on this podcast and failed miserably why
would you pick such a smart vocation to
start off with well you know because I'm
an arrogant ass oh I sleep well last
night you know I you know I got my big
big birthday coming up my 50th birthday
so my deal was there's a certain weight
I wanted to get down to and one of those
gene companies you know that advertised
on my podcast I can't remember the
[ __ ] name of him it's one of those
people you know we were two broke
college kids so we started a [ __ ]
gene Factory it's like well how the [ __ ]
did you do that I thought you were broke
you know you're trying to be all
down-to-earth and next thing you know
you got out you got a [ __ ] company
what are you telling me you just sewed
them yourself yeah we'll make you a pair
of pants it'll be about I don't know
well we gotta learn how to sew first
well cuz we're broke sure we can't
afford any sewing machines and people
that know how to operate them okay
apology accepted I'm saying I'm sorry
too for yelling but you know if you want
jeans from us it's just gonna take a
moment so stand up on this thing so I
can measure your inseam
[Music]
so anyways they sent me a pair of jeans
that were 3232 when I had a you know
that was 34 32 and now I'm 33 32 so my
goal is to get back to that's I think
that's the size that I had in high
school / when I started I started doing
comedy so I'll see if I can I don't know
I don't know if I want to do that
because you know this one of those
things where like if you're if you're
your high school weight when you're my
age but you never really went up I don't
think you look that bad but like if you
get down to your high school weight and
you were actually like an adult males
weight you kind of look like you're
dying but we'll see I am back on my
little health kick here I told you last
Monday you know I did the go i DM comedy
GM and I had a shot of Jameson before
the show you know sort of a tradition
you know drink a little shot of [ __ ]
courage and then after the show I went
out I was just gonna have one beer and
just gonna go home but I showed up and
somebody already bought me another
Jameson so I had that then I had a beer
but you know the shot and the beer was
stretched way out between the first like
the whole show went by like three hours
and I had a couple of waters after the
first shot so it was really just the
shot of Jameson and the beer and the
next day I woke up and aside from the
fact I stayed out till 1:00 in the
morning my lovely daughter gets up at
like 6:00 6:30 I just woke up and I
wasn't worth [ __ ] until like [ __ ]
2:00 in the afternoon and I was just
like I can't like I can't do this I just
can't [ __ ] do this so I didn't drink
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday and then
Friday I performed at arguably my
favorite theater in the country the
Brady theater in Tulsa Oklahoma
it's I cannot expect [ __ ] place and
the people that show up there and the
way the laughs sound in that room and
the sound and the look at that [ __ ]
place it's it's unreal in the amount of
people to who've never been there when I
told him I was going to Tulsa Oklahoma
they were like Tulsa Jesus you know
thinking that it was gonna be like
tumbleweeds and stuff it's a really
[ __ ] hipster replace like the food
scene alone is crazy and you know when
the food is really good then you're
gonna have the record store which I like
the record store I don't necessarily
like you know the douches that go in
there you know I you know I'm a douche
stupid like I was actually riffing about
that on stage for people like dude it
sounds so much better it's like I can't
hear the difference I can't hear that
didn't know the CD was it was a lime and
everything got compressed until they
just get into the whole [ __ ] sound
thing and I'm just I just like records
because they reminded me when I was a
kid you know and you feel like he kind
of got more for your money well you know
you'd open it up and there was all these
pictures on the inside sleeve and all of
that [ __ ] I don't know as opposed to now
you just download it off off like iTunes
and it's just floating in the air man so
anyways I so gifs getting off stage that
night it was like I'm not gonna drink
and I just felt like you know the habit
of me doing that being like come on man
just have [ __ ] one because I was
flying after the show it was like that
show in Tulsa was every [ __ ] reason
why I ever wanted to be a comedian it
was so much [ __ ] fun I was barely
doing my act I forget what I did I know
why I I connected I flew to Dallas
connected there and then went up to
Tulsa and the second I got on the plane
tells her like that was just like three
or four really big people you know not
just fat but just big-ass [ __ ] people
so I was just riffing on that one of
them two people was so big and fat they
had to use wheelchair so I was just
riffing on the fact you know
are you really helping them out if
you're wheeling them around like a
[ __ ] toddler and you know it's like
I'm not trying to like bring back
segregation here but I really think
wheelchairs should just be for people
who can't [ __ ] whose legs don't work
it's like your legs work you [ __ ] lay
off the cookies actually said yep see it
guys so fat that even if he has a full
head of hair you can still see most of
his scalp you know because even then
it's just get even his head is getting
like fat it's like stretching out it was
unbelievable this guy sat in the chair
in front of me and the [ __ ] chair was
like coming down and it was one of those
things like an action movie like is this
gonna [ __ ] stop or am I gonna get
crushed to death and it stopped about
two inches from the bridge of my nose
and I think I audibly exhaled like you
know because like you watching that guy
trying to get up he'd be like my
daughter she still can't do like a
sit-up you don't I mean she just doesn't
have the strike that it's hilarious she
gets like three inches up and she's
making this face and she's staring at ya
and then I just start laughing and then
she laughs which you know makes her fall
back down again so anyways she say Dada
Dada now all the time if she was in the
crib this morning I'm always the one
that goes out and I get her and then you
know pick her up and I figured out
because she gives the best hugs but
she's also you know a toddler now so she
just wants to look at everything so only
shows you only does it for half a second
so the way to trick her into giving you
a nice minute long hug it's you got to
sing to her and she loves the itsy bitsy
spider right now like that that's her
[ __ ] jam right so I just come out
there and she's like hi hi hi hi you
know showing off the word that she knows
how to say and then I just pick her up
and she gives me the quick hug and then
immediately is pointing over to the
changing table because you know she
wants to get that over with so she could
then go in and watch her little cartoons
you know and drink her bottle of milk
right but I got it down now I just pick
her up and I just go
itsy-bitsy spider went up the water
spout down came the rain and washed the
spider out and by then she's already
laid her head I sing it sweeter than
that I kind of push through with you
guys didn't want to creep you out but
she [ __ ] puts her head down on my
shoulder it just sits there is content I
can sing the song like six times in a
row and she'll just lay there and then
when I get sick of that song I just sing
the ABCs and and then she does this
thing if you squeeze her and you go give
me a hug her two little fat hands she
grabs two handfuls of your shirt it's
[ __ ] adorable
I'm starting to realize why dads cry at
their daughter's wedding you know I used
to think it was some weird [ __ ] like
they were just like thinking like oh
this guy's good even though even if they
haven't already banged he's gonna bang
her now tonight you know oh god you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I gotta pretend like
I like you know thinking like that [ __ ]
it isn't they're thinking about the it's
you bit like I used to sing this kid the
itsy-bitsy spider you know where did the
[ __ ] decades go
so anyways going back to my you know the
boozing and [ __ ] like I don't know so
then you know then that's like that's
already gonna be the greatest moments of
my life are gonna be those and I just
don't want to be all banged up and extra
tired and God forbid grumpy so I don't
know so then San Antonio I did two shows
[ __ ] amazing crowds down there
once again I just carried over whatever
happened in Tulsa I've learned how to do
that though as far as like what happens
as a you know when you go out and one
night you're just in the zone and you're
not even doing your act
the next night you come onstage you're
like hoping that you're going to be in
the zone again the night before you
weren't hoping that you were going to be
in the zone it just happened so then
you're going out there now you're hoping
it's going to be like last night
so now you're walking on a stage and
you're thinking about last night so
you're not you're not like mentally
they're not to get all trippy so what I
do is I try to let go of the last night
but do the same [ __ ] thing that I did
in that I'll just talk about something I
just [ __ ] saw except this time it's
in San Antonio and I just came out and I
was bitching about the fact that I
didn't realize that the final [ __ ]
was in San Antonio I kind of figured it
out when it was five hundred bucks a
night at a goddamn Red Roof Inn but up
by the [ __ ] airport and then it was
just like there's gonna be a real
problem with transportation I had to
hire this company you know to make sure
they could pick me up the airport get
Dean you know it was out there with del
rey del rey [ __ ] murdered so hard in
Tulsa
he had a sustained round of applause
like he had to wait before he introduced
me that's how [ __ ] hard this guy's
killing so you got to go see Dean when
he's out on the road actually watched
him do like a full set I know he has an
album coming out two on vinyl
I believe speaking of records so anyways
I went out and just did the same thing
and on both shows I just you know [ __ ]
around and rift about some [ __ ] and it
just got me into this place and then it
was fun because I was you know both
nights I was teasing people about having
ar-15s
and telling them how they should go
about talking to people on the left
about why you have an ar-15 and it just
just was a [ __ ] great night both
nights so what is my point so my point
is I just you know through I was
watching the Zen diaries of Garry
Shandling this [ __ ] incredible
documentary that Judd Apatow did and it
is such the stand-up comedian experience
I literally had to take breaks from it I
had to shut it off or hit pause I'll be
watching the thing right and I would
just
something he would write down because
Gary I guess kept all these diaries and
stuff and judges would just like film
like just a line or two that he wrote
and it would either be something that I
thought or something that I never
realized and it's just like yeah that's
it or just an experience that I had and
obviously all my experiences are on a
way less like whatever experience he had
at The Tonight Show are hosting the
Emmys I had plane you know uncle [ __ ]
ease and you know Swampscott
Massachusetts but I just kept fun I
would be watching this just hilarious
it'd be watching the show and he would
be like in the other room and then she
just hear me in the other room just
going like and just watching how the way
this thing is put together I'm not gonna
ruin it for you but just seeing how like
one like major event when you're a kid
with your developing mind be it positive
or negative
how it just shapes and informs the rest
of your life and the way that it is done
is so [ __ ] masterful in this
documentary and I don't I just can't say
enough I don't things about it so I was
sitting there after having watched it or
actually I had watched up to the like
the first half-hour this of part two it
means like four and a half hours long
and it's [ __ ] amazing and I was
actually out on the road going [ __ ] I
wish I could watch the rest of that
right now you know it's just you know
it's hard to find four-and-a-half hours
when you got you know you got a 14 month
old to just sit down in a row so that
was out there and I was just thinking
about you know I was mad at myself that
I went out after Tulsa and I had a drink
I had one drink and then somebody sent
one over to me and of course I'm gonna
drink that because I don't want to be
rude and you know I'm a bit of a booze
hound and I kind of just was thinking to
myself like I told myself I wasn't gonna
drink until [ __ ] June and I already
[ __ ] up on the road
because I wanted to just out of like you
know I'm flying high I'm [ __ ]
wide-awake I don't want the night to end
you know I'm too awake to [ __ ] go is
still to sleep I got an 8:00 a.m. flight
let me just [ __ ] have one and then
next thing you know I'm [ __ ] staying
out till like 1:00 in the goddamn
morning I got to get up at 6:00 for the
Flex what am i doing
I should be out of here getting sleep
for when I come back so I can be a
better dad this is stupid so because I
watched you know at that point the first
half of the Zen Diaries thing I actually
had a notebook because I was writing out
some of the drum parts for these songs I
got to sing with del Rey not saying
sorry play on Tuesday night out here at
the Avalon and I was just like why don't
you guys write down you know these goals
because some have a fee sometimes if you
just [ __ ] think them they're not real
and then I feel Sam or write them down
anyways how my brain works it becomes
real so I just kind of wrote it down the
[ __ ] that I wanted to do you know the
shape I wanted to be in and yeah I just
wrote down that I was just for the month
of April I'm just like I'm not smoking
any [ __ ] cigars I'm not drinking any
booze you know not watching any [ __ ]
porn you know [ __ ] stupid online porn
lonely [ __ ] you do on the road and that
porno I swear to god it's gonna come out
like how bad that is for you your brain
you know what I mean because I find
myself that when I watch porno laughing
like I'm watching a sitcom there's
always something that just strikes me is
[ __ ] funny
yeah it's just like I shouldn't be
laughing what was this weird right and
then you also think like you know you go
back I don't know how many [ __ ] years
like if you went back like a hundred
years and you showed somebody like a
laptop and be like you know you realize
you can watch this and you just put it
on I swear to god they would burn you at
the stake like you were a [ __ ] witch
like how [ __ ] up it would be that a
human being could sit down anytime they
wanted and just watch endless hours of
that [ __ ]
I bet I did some brain damage something
it's like you [ __ ] it's like you I
really feel like destroying my soul by
watching that [ __ ] on some level so I
was like gonna not do that I'm gonna
[ __ ] continue to work out all of
these just sort of these these these I
don't know health goals and then I got
to work on my my anger issues because my
daughter doesn't realize I have them yet
and it's just inevitable she's going to
I've been doing this joke on my act out
like a couple of times she seen me start
just like she if she honestly hasn't
even met me yet as far as like who I
really am
she's met decided me that I'm proud of
but all this [ __ ] that I'm ashamed of
she hasn't really met yet she's seen a
couple of glimpses but I'm always able
to joke my way out of it like oh she's
laughing because she doesn't know what
those words mean or that that behavior
is [ __ ] up right so I don't know
that's just [ __ ] I have to work on so I
don't know I don't think I would have
written that down and it would have
become real had I not watch that Zedd
Diaries a Garry Shandling I'm telling
man you got if you got a [ __ ] and see
that thing it's speaking with HP Elle's
killing it this month because they have
like they got one on a documentary on
like Andre the Giant Martin Luther King
Elvis I mean they just didn't mean and I
think it comes out every Wednesday so if
you're not watching the NHL rivalry
[ __ ] Wednesday or even if you are
just tape some of these things because
you know HBO they always do everything
[ __ ] top shelf it's gonna be amazing
so anyways I have some things to have I
made you guys laugh once yet I've just
been [ __ ] being an idiot here talking
about this [ __ ] but it's also key I just
feel like I'm doing this for me alright
got a couple of announcements here the
one I'm transitioning no kidding
October 6 2008 een I'm going to be in
Bridgeport Connecticut alright at
Webster
Bank Arena general public on sale will
be Friday April 6th at noon April 6th
when I'm gonna be in Pittsburgh but two
shows what an idiot I did people already
know I'm gonna be there I'm literally
hyping other shows I'm trying to hype
this new one October 6 2018 Bridgeport
Connecticut
Webster Bank Arena general public on
sale will be Friday April 6 at noon the
pre-sale starts today today all right
the code is Billy Baldwin get it Billy
bald wind all capital letters no spaces
B I ll be al D for the wind wi n anyways
you know what's [ __ ] hilarious I I did
the Brady theater in Tulsa I pull up and
this is one dude standing outside you
know the [ __ ] the stage door alright
and I got this thing I hate meeting
people before the show after the show I
don't give a [ __ ] but before the show I
can't it just it's weird to me it's like
I haven't done my [ __ ] thing that I
do so I'm thinking about doing that you
know I don't know I I no problem after
before it just wigs me out so I go to
and this guy goes he's like hey Bill big
fare get America and I go to sign his
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I'll listen I feel like
this sticky thing like I had like syrup
in my hand or something I hand it back
the pen and I look down on my [ __ ]
hand it's just come I get the ink the
pen exploded
oh [ __ ] I don't like I don't know what I
look like so I walk in and it's really
like thick like black or blue ink i won
in the bathroom and I'm like trying to
scrub the skin off my [ __ ] hand and
you know Delray's laughing at me and
[ __ ] look at literally [ __ ] you know my
hands are so pasty so I got this but
it's like my hands are in black face
right so I'm [ __ ] scrubbing this [ __ ]
off and I was able to get most of it off
there's still like you know you can see
the stain of it I wish I talked about
that when I went out on stage but I
didn't so I went out and I did the show
and as I go to walk off the stage who
comes walking down to the front of the
stage a bill but bla bla bla bla I
already met you I already signed your
[ __ ] and I already got the ink all over
my hand but he's getting married so
going on I wish a man thank you I go you
know good luck with your marriage and
everything so that I [ __ ] walk out
right just talking to Dean I'm like Dean
how [ __ ] unbelievable is that theater
you think uh you know the sound is I
believe a crap about blah you know Dean
that show is fire right so we go outside
and we go to leave the place that's like
10 or 15 people there right so I'm
[ __ ] hey guys thanks for coming out
talk to people you know signing [ __ ] or
whatever and this [ __ ] guy comes up
again and he wants me to sign more [ __ ]
I'm thinking in my head it's just like
this guy coming back for [ __ ] seconds
anyway you know there's other people
here we already did this and I shook
your hand
so I go to sign something [ __ ] else
that he has and I feel this sticky thing
he gave me this and I was so stupid that
I wouldn't I grabbed the thing I think
it's like that you [ __ ] [ __ ] I go
you got an exploded pen here and then he
just starts laughing and now I got this
[ __ ] on my [ __ ] hand my hands all
exact say almost the exact same fingers
and all that obviously I'm not a meat
dexterous switching my hands on I'm just
like in Dean's [ __ ] and then Dean
signed something from so we both walked
back into the [ __ ] car
we got ink all over our hands the
drivers laugh at his ass off at us cuz
he saw me when I went in going that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that exploded pen so as
this is thick as I go to get in the car
the same dude who I already signed his
[ __ ] got ink on my hand shook his hand
after the [ __ ] show you know as I'm
walking offstage shook his hand sign
more [ __ ] got more [ __ ] exploded in
my hand he then goes he goes hey Bill
you got a Pio address
I can send these things to these
pictures I took on his cellphone just go
now you [ __ ] ass all I got ain't go
over my hand again he just starts
laughing and then I felt bad I go good
luck with your marriage and we get in
the cars would drive it away and I just
was just riffed about the poor woman
that is gonna marry that [ __ ] guy you
know because it was something about him
you couldn't get mad at him but I really
think that that exploding pen was a
[ __ ] omen you know that he was just
gonna be like I don't know Jesus Christ
so anyways I let me read a little bit of
advertising then I'll tell you about San
Antonio I'm going down there with the
final four experience going on where the
hell is it what do we got here what do
we got this week oh don't you know talk
about how a made-to-measure suit fits
compared to a generic off-the-rack suit
well unless you're like a generic off
the rack size I imagine your ankles are
gonna be showing and your balls are
gonna be snugged or you know you're
gonna be looking like you have your big
brothers pants on if you're a little
shorty I mean obviously do I really need
to explain to people that if they
actually take your [ __ ] measurements
I mean if they take your measurements
it's gonna fit the way it's supposed to
fit you know and all of a sudden women
are gonna be looking at you like oh
who's that guy look at all [ __ ] sharp
in his suit as opposed to trying to hit
the lottery and being like you know did
the [ __ ] person in El Salvador that
sewed this together you know was he the
same size as me guys love the wide
selection of high quality fabrics and
the option to personalize all the
details including your lapel lining and
monogram that's kind of cool and you can
pick out your own lapel and the lining
right so later on that night you know
and you're on your date you take your
jacket off and you [ __ ] you put it
around the back of the chair you get a
little flash there monogrammed you're
taking yourself seriously all of a
sudden the woman thinks you [ __ ]
you're running something
back when guys used to go by you know by
the initial assistance mhg well say
here's how it works
visit a showroom or shop online in Indo
Chino com
pick your fabric choose your
customizations submit your measurements
wait for your custom suit to arrive in
just a few weeks after I need a suit for
the rough and rowdy thing I should have
ordered one through them anyways though
this week my listeners can get any
premium indochina suit for just 379
bucks at endo chino calm when entering
burr at checkout that's 50% off the
regular price for a major measure
premium suit plus shipping is free
that's Indochina Calm promo code BIR for
any premium suit for just 379 bucks and
free shipping incredible deals for a
suit that will fit you better than
anything off the rack ever could well
I'm looking for a unique suits to wear
at these rough and rowdy things alright
so maybe I'll go through these guys you
know provided everything go I just think
everything's gonna go well at this
provided the people at bar still want me
to come back for the next one because
I'm already I'm already ready to come
back for the [ __ ] next one and I
haven't even been to this one yet and
it's on April 13th in Charlotte North
Carolina
ok it's it's got to be on pay-per-view I
believe it's like 16 bucks
it's the biggest no-brainer ever get
your friends over sit down and just
watch regular people talk [ __ ] and go in
the ring and just [ __ ] wail on each
other it's it's the greatest [ __ ]
idea I don't know every once in a while
I I know I keep saying this but you know
I'm so psyched I'm gonna have ringside
seats he'll be sitting ringside for the
whole [ __ ] thing that'll be another
added thing cuz I don't know I don't
know how to commentate I'm not Joe Rogan
you know Joe Rogan is borderline of
[ __ ] a Mossad agent with his
abilities and his understanding of
combat me on the other hand I'm just
gonna sound like I was just some loud
[ __ ] head
next year on your couch okay that's what
I'm gonna do all right MVM tea movement
here's my problem with sunglasses I
didn't know I had a problem of
sunglasses why are you putting words in
my mouth I got all these cheap pairs
that look terrible no I don't I have
nice pairs but every time I buy 200 pips
you want a dollar pair I feel like I get
ripped off that's not what I feel here's
my problem with sunglasses okay if you
buy a [ __ ] cheap pair they don't do
anything you're still squinting behind
them now your face is all mushed up
wearing sunglasses you look like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and they're digging into
the right above your ear and your scalp
but then if you buy a nice expensive
pair then you got to sit there gone like
oh my god oh my god what if I what if I
lose it what if I sit on him in a never
believe that [ __ ] happens okay
movement that's what I feel about
[ __ ] sunglasses how dare you put
words in my mouth and I don't feel like
I got ripped off if I paid $200 I feel
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] when I lose them
all right well our friends at at
movement
yeah the watch guys they kind of felt
the same way I don't know if they agreed
with me so they they thought screw it I
think they thought [ __ ] it
how about we make quality trendy glasses
at a fair price
these things aren't plastic they acetate
you can get them polarized is that a
word a state a state I got to add that
where I'm gonna [ __ ] it I'm gonna it's a
goal of mine today to throw that word in
with my wife see what the [ __ ] were that
[ __ ] does that mean
dude you ever gonna look up a [ __ ]
word on Wikipedia what is that writing
when you're trying to figure out how to
spell it
it looks like it's in Russian is it is a
salt form by a combination of a sette
acetic acid with an alkaline earthy
metallic base ah [ __ ] this out of I
don't give I don't need to know what it
means I just know how to say it
nobody knows nobody knows what this
[ __ ] word means you just say it
people like wow that guy's guy's smart
look at his custom lining on a suit all
right here we go
everybody it's this thing okay if your
support of this podcast you have to work
this word in into your day with somebody
who you that you know very well who's
gonna know that you have no idea what
this [ __ ] word means and your goal is
to try and [ __ ] play it off like
you've always had this in your arsenal
like this was part of your [ __ ]
pitching rotation here we go acetate
acetate you [ __ ] acetate there you go
kind of sounds like [ __ ] doesn't it
you [ __ ] acetate acetate do how
creepy is this this is like it's the end
of the world and that's like some
warning in the future you know I think
we just lost Mike all right sorry about
that that was my version of like alien
all you need in the background that
acetate acetate is that Oh Oh what's
going on here
acetate effects well I like learning
stuff when they when they have music
that makes you not think that has got to
be the worst [ __ ] fade down ever of
anything isn't it
I love gonna learn something Jesus
Christ how about a nice little fade now
hey stampers and today I'm gonna teach
you about how acetate acetate in the
future some day when you're dumb enough
to buy a [ __ ] robot one day when it
has a glitch and you come walking in
there and it has an even weirder robot
expression on its face and you're like
hey what's up there [ __ ] r2d2 and
it's just looking at you going acetate
acetate acetate why are you saying that
man and slowly walking towards you
acetate anyways what the [ __ ] was I
talking about so sunglasses they have
lots of styles to choose from wait
these things aren't plastic they acetate
acetate acetate you can get them
polarized and they start at just $70
they're seriously my go-to shades I
don't have a [ __ ] pair yet send them
to me I want these things hey Bill what
you get those sunglasses I'm just gonna
stare at them like the [ __ ]
terminator ah stupid acetate they are
high-quality premium acetate acetate
acetate frames no cheap plastic here you
got to see these they have lots of
styles to choose from
classic trendy round a VA mirrored
polarized I love guns
[ __ ] it that's polarized for him and for
her you're sure to find the perfect pair
get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t.com slash
/ you know about movement for how
they've revela revolutionized the watch
industry they've already done that this
is like a fighter that's moving up in
weight class they already got that belt
now they're gonna go for the next one
now is the time to check out their
sunglasses go to movement comm / /
that's m/v as in
M T as in toodaloo dot-com / bird
joined the movement acetate acetate me
undies everybody oh here we go
boat oh doot doot me undies me undies
nice soft [ __ ] against your taint but do
doot doot me undies me undies they don't
[ __ ] acid taint why would you want
that [ __ ] up against your skin
especially down there there is no wind
wash it off with your ladies face sorry
you've you've heard me talk about me
undies and you know that I'm a big
believer and their product they're the
perfect balance of comfort and fit every
month they have new and exciting prints
and they arrive at your door in a fun
bag yeah they sent me another sack of
underwear one of them were like referee
shorts I don't know how I felt about
those it's like what am I gonna [ __ ]
be rat and paint a lot now throwing
flags and stuff me undies uses lensing
micro mode what the [ __ ] is lensing
lensing lensing in their underwear
it's sustainably sourced what does that
mean they can grow morph are they
planting lensing micro mode modal trees
naturally soft fibre that starts with
beech wood trees and ends with the most
amazing fabric you've ever experienced
how the [ __ ] you cut down a tree and
make comfortable underwear it's just
just goes to show you the level of
genius although if you had to like you
know put you undercarriage up against
the tree I think a beechwood tree would
probably be a nicer one
you know it's got the smooth bark right
the results have been downright dreamy
the undies adventurous prints and
designs are all limited edition and new
patterns are released every few weeks on
a rolling basis 100% satisfaction
guaranteed me undies guarantees you will
love their undies or your money back the
undies has a great offer for my
listeners for any part-time first-time
purchasers when you purchase any me
undies you get 20% off and free shipping
the undies is so sure you'll love their
underwear
they offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee
if you don't love your first pair you'll
get a full refund this is a no-brainer
get get 20% off a pair of the most
comfortable underwear you will ever put
on do you hear somebody's screaming oh
she's got the cartoons on saw some weird
lady came in the [ __ ] room in the
house I mean not to get 20% off your
first pair free shipping hunter sent
satisfaction guaranteed go to me undies
calm / bird that's me unease calm / /
hang on a second I gotta go to turn that
down a little bit I don't know if you
could hear that I use acetate like two
or three times and she just looks up she
goes I don't know what that word means
and I don't care - so there you go
that's right you know that's a good one
to use on your lady she'll think that
you [ __ ] moving on you know you see
Jessie getting smart see right there
that's what I want to work on my temper
I was just literally trying to bring the
cord around my foot and I couldn't do it
because I'm not flexible enough and I
just said get the [ __ ] off me like it
was a person there's something wrong
about that
alright stamps calm stay at Strom brings
all the amazing services of the US
Postal Service right to your fingertips
by imprint official US postage for any
letter any package any class of mail
using your own computer and printer
stamps or comms makes it easy they'll
send you a digital scale automate
automatically calculates exact postage
stamps comm will even help you decide
the best class of mail based on your
needs no need to lease
an expensive postage meter and there are
no long term commitments I use stamps
calm because I don't know why you said
cuz you [ __ ] you buy advertising on
this thing and I ended up using it it
turned out to be easy but I'll be like
you know I did it for the money man and
then it turned out to be a great great
thing I don't have to go to the post
office when I send out my [ __ ] post
it's alright anyways
and right now you too can enjoy stamps
to the stamps.com service with a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus postage and a digital scale go to
stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in bird
that stamps comm enter bar alright what
else did I want to talk about Oh another
thing with that Garry Shandling think
that that documentary really affected me
was you know one of the things that
happens to a lot of comedians is
whatever the [ __ ] happened to us that
made us become comedians you just start
chasing you know selling out clubs and
get known and becoming famous and all
that and thinking that that's gonna
[ __ ] you know get rid of your demons
and it doesn't and then you put off a
major part of your life which is finding
love and starting a family and all of
that [ __ ] and you know the other day I
was talking to somebody and they were in
their early 30s and I brought up the
Garry Shandling documentary and the
person said who's that right and then I
also mentioned like somehow I brought up
Robin Williams and I mentioned that he
had you know committed suicide a few
years and she and she didn't even
realize he it was dead and she was just
like mrs. Doubtfire that was like and in
my head I'm just going these people are
[ __ ] legends it's just like you know
every generation has their people you
know what I mean so it's like it was
like so [ __ ] profound what it's like
you chasing all of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] and you know once she you know once
you're past a certain age like no one's
gonna give a [ __ ] anymore anyways so
it's like you're trying to I don't know
it's not like a tangible thing that you
can depend on and I had this big fear
when I was going through comedy that I
was like I was like I could be the guy
that doesn't get married and never has
kids because I've seen the other side of
that it's like I don't want to [ __ ] I
don't want to end up being that cliche
and then just being that [ __ ] if that
older [ __ ] comic you know and then
you got your sport coat on to hide your
middle and you're talking if you're
talking at this point you're hitting on
women that don't know who your bands are
and don't know all your cultural
references they don't even know who
these [ __ ] people are and other the
level of [ __ ] sadness that how lonely
that feeling would be I used to [ __ ]
wake up I didn't literally wake up but I
would be laying in bed on the road
thinking about [ __ ] like that and when I
was watching this documentary I remember
you know thinking as I was watching Gary
wrestling with his demons I literally
said to me at one point I was like
marrying you and having a kid as a
smartest [ __ ] thing I ever did thank
God I know I didn't late but thank God I
[ __ ] did that because if I didn't you
know I'd be seventy years old in some
[ __ ] goddamn Hotel on the other side
of this [ __ ] when nobody gave a [ __ ] and
I would just be laying there drinking
myself to death going acetate acetate
that literally makes me scared just
saying that acetate anyways so I think
what I'm gonna do cuz I don't think I'm
a diary person but I think what I'm
gonna do is I'm just gonna kind of write
down in the beginning of the day just I
find out just one day of doing that it's
really vivid and it lives now rather
than just being this [ __ ] random
thought like you know I need to work on
this maybe just have a [ __ ] goal each
day so my kid I can kind of kill off
this [ __ ] anger demon that exists in
my family tree
I would love to see my family tree it's
got to look like I'd be this weird
combination of like oh that's really
nice but a little upsetting you know
like a tree in the beginning of winter
at a certain time a day you know you
know that certain time of day wood trees
are beautiful but they start to look a
little ominous that's probably what it
would look like a tree that's trying all
right let's uh oh I didn't tell you guys
about my [ __ ] journey back from San
Antonio so I had a 6:00 a.m. flight to
Tulsa Oklahoma
you know I normally I would have flown
into the night before but I got the kid
you know I can't can't miss those hours
so I flew in no problem everything was
great the next day I had an 8:00 a.m.
flight to San Antonio for whatever
[ __ ] reason I mean it's not that long
a flight we're in the same time zone how
come I couldn't get like the ten o'clock
flight right so we check into the hotel
we do the show everything's great and
then the next morning I had a 6:00 a.m.
flight and I got off stage at 12 and
couldn't get to sleep - like like 1:30
2:00 in the morning
so I was just like alright I'll just
sleep on the plane
so we get up at like 4:30 in the [ __ ]
morning quarter to 5:00 go down there
and my big thing is when I only get like
two hours sleep all I'm trying to do is
get on the plane and once I get on the
[ __ ] plane it's like I'm just gonna
go to sleep you know I forgot my eye
mask and one [ __ ] always has to have
their [ __ ] shade up you know cuz
they're a morning person and [ __ ]
everybody else you know no consideration
for somebody who just [ __ ] stopped
working at you know 12:00 12:30 right so
we get there and I'm laughing at Dean
because we are like so [ __ ] tired
it's like you literally like you
hungover or like dude all I got to do is
get on that plane and he's like I know
I'm gonna go right to sleep and then I'm
gonna land at 7:30 LA time right by the
time I get to my [ __ ] house it's
gonna be 8:30 my daughter just got up a
half hour early I'm gonna get that whole
time right there before she does her
first nap [ __ ] perfect
and all of a sudden they're like the
flights now gonna [ __ ] leave at 6:15
you know cuz they said they had to reset
the airplane but I don't know what the
[ __ ] that means is that some computer
[ __ ] I have no idea
and then 6:15 became 6:45 and I was like
oh god don't do this please don't do
this and then it became 7:45 and then it
got [ __ ] cancelled and then because
it was the final for all the [ __ ]
planes were sold out and the next one
they could get us on was 7 p.m. and I
was like trying to keep my cool which of
course I didn't and they said sir it's
ok we're going to send everybody on the
7 o'clock flight we're gonna send on an
excursion today paid by Delta I'm like I
don't want to go on an excursion I want
to go to Los Angeles and she goes
they're gonna take you to Sea World
it's like oh yeah are they gonna buy me
a giant [ __ ] lollipop I don't want to
[ __ ] I don't want to watch an
incarcerated killer whale doing [ __ ]
jumping through a hula hoop okay I don't
wanna see that what I would can I go
there and watch you set that [ __ ]
thing free again I would see that that
would be worth it you know watch it jump
over a little boy as it goes out out of
the bay into a [ __ ] the ocean like
Free Willy so anyways so we say [ __ ]
Delta not [ __ ] Delta literally [ __ ]
Delta but [ __ ] this situation Delta put
us in cuz I know all the airlines it's
just a it happens ok the [ __ ] planes
not working right I understand it but
I'm also frustrated so I go down to
Southwest all of this [ __ ] is filled up
so we're like what about Dallas can he
fly us to Dallas like Love Field and
we'll just fly back can't do that
and then we just said what about Austin
and they go ok well Austin we have a
10:00 a.m. flight at this point it's
like you know getting close to 9:00 we
have an 11 and we have a 2:15 so I'm
like alright put us on the [ __ ] 2:15
and when it's an hour-and-a-half Drive
so Dean goes to get a [ __ ] rental car
and I said [ __ ] this let's just over
then we don't have to deal with picking
up the rental car the shuttle and all
that so we did [ __ ] ubered I passed
out in the [ __ ] car
I got out of the car I left my [ __ ]
headphones in that this is my third time
second time I've lost those Bose
headphones I always keep the charge of
them if anybody has a set of those
silver [ __ ] bows or the black ones
and you need that little charger cord
send me your address and I'll mail it t
because I'm gonna have three of them as
I just ordered another [ __ ] pair so
anyways we get out and we got there so
[ __ ] fast cuz there was no traffic we
actually got on the 11:15 had to connect
through [ __ ] Phoenix it wasn't that
bad and it all worked out and and
because I written down that [ __ ] you
know that I wanted to like maybe talk to
somebody about my temper or something
like that
I was actually completely aware that I
was [ __ ] snapping when I snapped like
that's that's as far as I've ever been
able to get to with my temper you know
the old me I would just snap and not
think about it now I'm actually thinking
about it as I do it and have no control
over it so it's even more like torturous
now because now like watching myself oh
yeah you go bill yelling at people that
like built they're trying to save your
life do you think they're not flying
because they want to go through this
giant [ __ ] headache on some level
they're probably losing money because
one of their planes cannot fly would you
like to get up to a cruising altitude
and then plunge back to the [ __ ]
earth and never see your family again Oh
boohoo you have to wait 12 hours to
continue living you selfish stupid [ __ ]
but I can't hear anything at that point
I'm in the [ __ ] acetate mode alright
I'm killing that joke by the way
I am so back into Def Leppard now it's
ridiculous I downloaded pyromania and
was it high and dry the one before that
and I'm so into them I'm actually
looking at left-handed flying V's you
know like maybe this is the guitar I'll
know how to [ __ ] I'll actually stick
with because I was just watching the
illini but they what's that guy's name
Pete
this is the guy that they had on the
high and dry and then they had
what's-his-face filled in for him
I always forget his [ __ ] name and
it's literally the same name as somebody
else famous it's Phil Collen not Phil
Collins he came in and filled in for him
but like that that album
pyromania when that came out that's just
one of those albums that came out during
this awesome time in your life first
time he had crushes on [ __ ] chicks in
your grade and [ __ ] and that [ __ ]
album came out you know and I did the
this is what I would do rather than
thinking what can I say to this chick in
my [ __ ] class that I like that's lady
I would actually just I would just go
home instead and I would listen to
pyromania fantasizing that I was in the
band playing the guitar and singing in
front of the school and even in the
fantasies she would just see me do it
and I would still never talk to her I'm
a [ __ ] mess and that's what leads you
then it's just like well I can't sing
and I can't play guitar I guess I'll go
up there and tell [ __ ] jokes I guess
think they tie I became a comedian
all right rough and rowdy Charlotte
April 13th Billie's gonna wear a [ __ ]
silly suit and he's gonna [ __ ] make
some jokes you got to watch it
pay-per-view all right f1 dear silly
Billy greetings from Monaco all the
sovereign state on the French Riviera
originally from Portugal I'm a very big
f1 fan since I was four years old well
it seems like you saw the heyday of it
the second golden age of it with Michael
Schumacher my grandfather says I
wouldn't take my eyes off the cars even
if a storm took the roof off the house
it's a beautiful and graceful sport
despite how loud it can be I first saw
you from Chapelle and then saw you on an
interview on the internet from Montreal
my brother showed me because he's a huge
fan of yours I now AM - that's great
thank you I think this is a very
important time in f1 the sport is going
to continue to move into the mainstream
because the stars in the sports and the
storylines of competition are starting
to match the popular culture of today
well that's very what's the word
all I can think of is acetate that's a
very astute analyzation is that the word
I know it can be very Shakespearean I
appreciate you talking about the drivers
with respect even if you're not a fan of
everything they do is incredible how
talented these men are and some women
are able to navigate with some women are
able to navigate with precision now
that's hilarious
will the chauvinism there I would like
very much to see you at more races and
perhaps talking to drivers and crews
thank you and bless your family oh you
and me both Oh a lovely Nia and my
lovely daughter you know what she has
the cutest outfit on today she is on
these gray sweatpants and pants with
this matching hoodie that short sleeve
it looks like you got a little Belichick
hi how are you how was your breakfast
rant and rave and screaming yelling your
podcast for damn near 15 years and you
know I never say anything and then I'm
having breakfast with our lovely
daughter and we're laughing and we're
joking or singing songs and you have the
nerve to come in and tell us to keep it
down
the company cheese I know no I'm just
yeah but this is also putting a roof
over our head what's up buddy how you
doing we can have fun today huh the itsy
bitsy spider went up the waterspout
watch the spider out out came the Sun
and dried up all the rain and the itsy
bitsy spider went up the spout again
[Music]
ah look at that smile alright you want
to read some of these with me now okay
what do we got here oh yeah I absolutely
would love to talk to the drive this
guy's saying he's from Portugal he now
lives in Monaco how much is this guy
crushing it and this is listen to what
he says about female drivers near list
of this he says it's incredible how
Talent these these men are and some
women are able to navigate with
precision oh thanks thanks for that
some women are what was he going with
this he was just saying that he would
love to see me talking to more drivers
and being a more racist oh well I know
you would like that I would love that
and I think if I could navigate with
precision down to the pit area and if
you don't trip and fall because you're a
woman right mm-hm yeah I'm a
chauvinistic Pig and I attract these
people they need a pot chauvinists neat
podcast - all right let's let's talk
about 45s you like records right huh
hey sweetie you want to talk about 45s
huh
you gonna tell us the story what's so
crazy right now she totally has
obviously has all these thoughts and she
knows what she's saying but she doesn't
understand that we don't talk her
gibberish so she'll just be sitting
there making all these hand movements
like she's making these profound points
and she's going I said sorry Chuck and
she's still making was she still into
that noisy crap that she was doing
okay can you say baby you say baby say
you like that frog and I break bad Nate
don't a Michigan
all right 45 say Billie burr hole a
longtime fan of the podcast well thank
you I travel a lot and your
Massachusetts vibes always remind me of
home
recently don't touch that don't touch
that don't touch that
recently it's so funny they always go
for like the thing that's gonna hurt
them the most there's all this stuff
here shoes chairs and all that goes
right for the hot tea recently my fiance
and I surrendered our weekend nights to
playing card games alongside tasty beers
at home I should just playing 45s that
sounds like fun yeah we were just saying
how we hate those like you go to those
parties with other adults and they have
game night it's always [ __ ] cards
against humanity' and all of that stuff
I don't want to do that but like food we
got to get to bring back cards right
yeah but cards are cool it's only
playing mad libs the jokes and cards
against humanity' are as bad as when you
fly Southwest I hate to make fun of
though because I love that airline but
listening those people do comedy I just
can't I get angry at the people
encouraging them through this guy was
certainly going down the you know we're
going down the runway like what go on
the tarmac or whatever and he's doing
the Darth Vader voice everybody put on
your feet bit people like no it just
annoys me that that person doesn't get
heckled because it's just like if I if I
did a joke like that people will be
throwing their chair at me and this
guy's getting laughs I feel like maybe
people feel obligated
cuz it's the the flight crew and you
want to be on their good side it's
exactly what it is it's the awkward
silence and people are just they in the
silence of the joke bombing people then
laugh because they feel uncomfortable
because this is overall nervousness that
what we're about to do could kill us so
then the level of comedy that they have
to do not I mean when you're scared
you'll laugh at anything you just walk
in like yeah
the rains really coming down isn't it
it's like you didn't say anything funny
there wow that was close
nervous laughter there we go
I suggest playing 45 which I know me are
you kidding me we got it we got it we
got to get a cool stereo man yeah I you
know what we should have our own kind of
like night you know and music you and me
why don't we do that sing some songs huh
hugging kissed a little bit while the
little ones down when we do that instead
of sitting there going like whatever
them yeah
yes innocent that cars again hurry as
old hmm I think Southwest writes those
punchlines on those stupid cards I did
so like that you don't write the
punchline and then you get credit for it
I'm sorry yeah I'm too unto into the to
far deep into the joke game anyways we
could hardly find any rule okay I
suggest playing 45s which I can which I
had always played growing up on the
North Shore in trying to find the rules
online I was surprised to learn that
it's pretty endemic to Massachusetts
what rules what are we talking about oh
they don't know about 45 like you don't
know what acetate means I guess so oh
yeah we could hardly can you do me a
favor can you say acetate three times in
a row with a pause
and just no life in your voice between
each one just pause just say acetate
three times in a row acetate acetate
acetate
I meant longer pause that was pretty
good
okay we'll definitely call you back for
the audition in any case just curious
whether you ever played this game girl
never had any other traditions you found
to be a massachusetts thing once you
left thanks and hope you can come to
Vermont or Montreal sometime soon okay
yes and yes oh I'm so old I thought you
sent about records because somebody gave
me some records in Tulsa and then the
one of them was a 45 so I'm gonna have
to get the adapter yeah watch it watch
it watch it no you just you just you
just want to spill that don't you all
right 40 45s game yeah yeah 45s game 45
it's a card game all right
why is my Internet's so slow all right
the ace of heart is always the best
third box I was played with the regular
deck of cards this isn't like old maid
you guys never old maid you know and
then the classic that I never played
granny [ __ ] water there's another
cane there's another card game Nia that
everybody in the Midwest knows about
euchre and that game would Joe part Nick
and j-law had talked about euchre they
were like freaking out there was going
like entire families had stopped talking
to each other on Christmas because of
that game that game is evil that's like
a Pittsburgh Cleveland Detroit that type
of area I think people play euchre the
Ace of Hearts is always the third best
Trump any week this is good this is good
clean fun here the deal robbing the
Trump object of the game the goal is to
accumulate the most chips by winning
tricks how to keep score irregularities
this is this is a game night bill so I
don't know why you're talking about
you're so against game night this is
because I'd like you know I don't like
the modern games I'll play cards my
grandmother was a bozo amazing and my
aunt against humanity
you ever play flinch flinch is another
one maybe gonna get all these card games
oh look at me Jimmy plate hearts that's
what white people play oh you guys we
got to get some cards man we got to get
some cards we explore each other's like
heritage through card games yeah you
teach me spades I got to remember how to
play hard I knew black people's like
dominoes well I know we're not talking
about dominoes why could you just give
me that that I actually knew something
but that was like the Chappelle's Show
sketch I know black people I just said
it okay Jesus okay sorry
she's so protective she's so protective
of her culture you know that Nia
oh you kissing the baby oh yeah why are
you so protective
I'm just want to start an argument of
you know why are you so protective of
your culture why don't you let me in
you've never taught me how to taught me
how to do you never taught me how to do
the do you know Nia can do the whole
Janet Jackson's Rhythm Nation dance yeah
that's the thing she'll just bust that
out out of [ __ ] sorry I don't know where
and she can really do it you don't I
mean it's not like me I could do like
the pee-wee Herman did that data edit
that I think I'm all impressed they've
all impressive right China's
surveillance Anya you know people gonna
ask you to [ __ ] Instagram that
not gonna happen well okay I'm back
sorry the batteries just died in this
thing all right we are I think I'm well
over an hour here at this point I have
to be I don't really know where I'm at
at this point all right
China's surveillance man all right if
you want me to just do the rest of this
because it seems like she's getting
ready to run around here so I just don't
know if that's gonna be annoying to
people to here god I love is I'm sitting
there talking about a list oh yeah
that's one thing you got to remember
your kid is adorable to you everyone
everybody thinks the kids adorable then
after a while it's just like okay okay
okay
China's surveillance deer bill Bunker
Hill I love it I'm a software engineer
make sure she doesn't shut our hands in
the door there Oh down like a ton of
bricks it is amazing that they always
fall in there but yeah all right buddy
all right cutie pie I'll see you in a
few minutes
bye-bye Oh
all right I'll see you lovely ladies out
there all right I'm a software engineer
and system integration specialists and a
prominent firm in a major city
I won't state my political affiliation
because I know you hate that move as
much as I do
good let's get into it I'm terrified
that my children will have little to no
privacy in their adult lives being
intact I'm becoming aware of the
capabilities and advances in
surveillance systems and as an ordinary
human being with the internet I've
maintained an understanding that our
government under both parties have been
constantly expanding their surveillance
reach and continue to lie to us about
what information is being stored yeah
it's ridiculous and all the major
[ __ ] news organizations don't say
anything about it they don't do anything
to protect us they just sit there
[ __ ] making money China isn't very
different it's definitely more
aggressive and more intrusive the big
this is what Snowden was trying to warn
us about we all left that guy twisting
on the vine and everybody was afraid
because they wrapped what this guy was
doing into trying to beat Isis so then
it was like well I can't say anything
cuz then I don't support the troops and
then I'm gonna get the Dixie Chicks
[ __ ] treatment that's that's all
that's all they're [ __ ] doing right
now
they're just destroying people
individually Snowden is a [ __ ] hero
as far as I'm concerned it's goddamn
[ __ ] lunatics it's like how much more
do they need to know about you just sit
down at the airport you go through
[ __ ] security then it's like you
don't understand in that now go now go
through TSA you gotta answer all this
[ __ ] and get [ __ ] fingerprinted and
now now that lines clogged up so now the
next one people have [ __ ] stick in
that goddamn retinas in there it's
unbelievable
alright drop your pants and spread your
butt cheeks is gonna be the next one to
get through the line [ __ ] quicker and
people would do it because it'll be more
convenient all right the biggest
difference is that they have the decency
to not try and hide it or maybe you
think it's better to be lied to I don't
know well I think it's because China can
just [ __ ] you know I know as far as I
know in mainland China you're the level
of rights that you have versus what you
have over here I think over here you
have to lie because they don't have the
right to do what they're doing probably
I don't know this article lays out the
way in which our government surveillance
is going to be able to access everything
in a Chinese citizens life both at work
and at home in which government on our
government one of the most important
advancements being made is not just the
collection of data but the sorting or of
data and the ability to sift through
billions of communications for specific
content this is why the FBI and CIA have
had information on terrorist activity
but had no way to access it if through
all the [ __ ] yeah so the thing is so
what people will say well as well as
least as long as I'm not out there
trashing a you know saying I'm a Muslim
I won't have a problem back to my kids
multi because this is the thing they're
going to use that to then access all
this other [ __ ] as they all
we still as they always do back to my
kids most government technology
eventually makes it makes its ways to
the public when my children are in their
adult life all of their previous years
will be stored somewhere to create a
case against them based on the person
that they were and not who they've
become Jesus Christ that last statement
there might be the most intelligent
thing anybody's ever sent in I will send
you guys this this link to this story
and read it and it just be informed and
know that you're gonna be all right all
right because I don't want to send all
this doomsday [ __ ] that's gonna make you
go into a depression but you also do
need to know it would be nice if people
knew what was going on and I think like
this is the time where people I just
feel like everybody wants to start
speaking up like what are we doing and
not in an anti USA [ __ ] way but you
know at some point somebody has to kind
of step up here you know I think we kind
of need to look at the finances of how
much this [ __ ] non ending war is
costing us and at some point we're gonna
have to pay all of that back seven
hundred billion dollars a [ __ ] year I
mean III really would really be a sad
thing
if 3,500 [ __ ] jerk-offs that train on
a jungle gym were to bankrupt this great
nation I mean some point we do have to
there has to be a way to discuss that
without somebody yelling at you saying
you don't support the troops just that
you know cuz maybe they haven't worked
out maybe there was a solution it would
be nice as a citizen who's paying
ungodly taxes who would like to see them
go to some [ __ ] over here like pump
making public schools good again
you know maybe get some people off the
streets that need some help you know all
these shutter island' people [ __ ]
walking around they used to have
facilities that they could go to you
combine that with the fact that they can
now go in and buy a bazooka and not have
to wait longer than three [ __ ] minutes
and all of a sudden you start to have
some problems don't bring that up why
did I blame myself for that you know
that's not true
I should sound like I got to get a good
good good corpora
raishin impression you're clearly
against the United States of America
wife believes in ghosts Jesus dear Billy
burger basket I love my wife dearly
you know most topics we are in agreement
but recently something has come between
us she believes in ghosts and I do not
dude [ __ ] let it go who gives a [ __ ]
okay as long as she's not trying to talk
to him and acting like Whoopi Goldberg
and saying that they're entering her
body but even then if she does that to
just dedicate one of your rooms to that
and just have her [ __ ] make money off
of other dopes that believe what she's
doing is real anyways I'm not so
bothered by her belief sure it's a bit
kooky but she's free to do it and so
it's not hurting anyone all right there
you go the problem is is that she's
offended that I don't believe in ghosts
as well oh look at that I gave you a
lecture and you were already [ __ ] you
were already where I was telling you to
go it's like okay you believe in ghosts
good for you but I don't fine Rock gross
is there anything worse than cold tea
sorry I just started coughing I had to
take a little swig there I stopped
believing ghosts around the same time I
stopped believing in Santa Claus and the
Easter Bunny back when I was a kid so
when a full-grown adult tells me they
see spirits I can't help but wonder if
there's something wrong with them
mentally she is afraid to go to the
restroom at a certain restaurant in our
town because there's a story about it
being haunted she says the last time she
went in there she felt an eerie chill
but it's a drafty bathroom in a
ninety-year-old build building for
Christ's sake
she also has this old photograph she
took through a window and an abandoned
mental hospital that she claims shows a
ghost face when I look at it I only saw
blurry [ __ ] I tried to be nice about
it but I think she felt like I was
calling her stupid or crazy when I
didn't see it when I didn't see it too I
didn't want to lie about it besides she
would know if I was lying anyways I
don't know how to approach this topic
without upsetting her do you have any
advice for me yours truly
this guy left his [ __ ] name I don't
know if this is a reference to somebody
at a movie let me see yes this has got
to be somebody uh this has to be a movie
joke Oh dr. Peter Venkman
okay this is Bill Murray's character and
Ghostbusters okay hilarious all right I
don't know how to approach this topic
without upsetting her do you have any
advice for me yours truly dr. Peter
Venkman
yeah don't bring up the topic don't
bring up the topic and you know I I
would just I would just be like look I
get it you believe in ghosts and I don't
don't say like that just feel like I
respect the fact that you believe in
ghosts and I don't and if the tables
were turned and there was something that
I believed in and you didn't I would
respect the fact that you didn't and
rather than you know getting upset with
you okay you see ghosts evidently you
are born with the power that I was not
giving so you should feel thankful for
that that you're able to see these
things I am a mere mortal well don't say
that because then that's
passive-aggressive I'm the worst
something along those lines they just
say listen I love everything about you
and we get along great but I just feel
like there's this tension about this
that that you're trying to force me to
feel something that I don't feel and I
don't think that that's what you do to
somebody you love and I wouldn't do that
to you okay so come on over here and if
there's not a ghost between us could you
give me a hug some along those lines all
right last one here my sister's friend
oh boy Hey hi bill you [ __ ] I'm an
eighteen year old from England and I
need some advice
all right you pasty crooked teeth douche
around two months ago one of my sisters
childhood friends came to visit her for
a weekend they've been friends since
they were three and she moved five hours
away when she was 12 so they barely see
each other anymore they were playing to
go out on
with a group of friends say and I was
planning on staying home alone when my
sister went to pick up a few of her
friends to meet at our house
me and her friends flirted a bit but
nothing major we exchanged snapchats
etc I love how that's flirting though
long time long story short my sister's
friend pretended to be ill and came home
early so we could hook up dude you have
[ __ ] crushing it your sister's
bringing them home too you know you have
to go out good for you the only thing
was my sister was genuinely ill and also
came home early around 30 minutes after
her friend and she caught us in bed
together well what the [ __ ] is she doing
walking into your bedroom my sister got
insanely angry and stormed out but you
should have say donate the player hit
the game they just lit a cigarette oh my
god I think this is [ __ ] funny
this is [ __ ] hilarious dude do you
realize how hard you're crushing it
you're [ __ ] at home you're not even
trying to get laid she just has her
friends come over for the [ __ ] okay
ladies you're ready to go out and in
that moment whatever the [ __ ] you did
made one of them pretend to be sick and
come back and hook up with you don't
you're a [ __ ] hero
there's no reason to get I don't care
how mad your sister gets just I would
just just keep smiling and just be like
hey I can't help Amanda like you know
the ladies love me sweetheart sweetheart
I wasn't trying to hook up I was at home
I was innocent I can't help it if women
are attracted to me I would just go
totally [ __ ] arrogant and no matter
she get I would just keep laughing and I
would never take it seriously
my sister has suffered with depression
and anxiety I get what I just
I didn't see that part my sisters
suffered with depression and I'm so
excited for you that I didn't even read
this next book she suffered with
depression and anxiety for years
whenever something like this happens my
family almost always sides with her oh
that's easy then you just divide and
conquer with you with your dad just be
like dad I can't help but I I inherited
your charisma what do you want from me
she got I didn't I didn't go out with
she came home to me if it fell right in
my lap what was I supposed to do dad
what was I supposed to do you know and
he'll I don't know but there's no
[ __ ] way I get mad at my kid in the
morning I mean he's mad because you're
making her upset but he's not mad at
what you did I'm guaranteed your dad's
telling his friends at work he's [ __ ]
the son of a [ __ ] did you have to leave
the [ __ ] house they're coming they're
coming at him in the morning she
threatened to never talk to me again for
what I did but I said something along
the lines of I feel a connection with
her there's some [ __ ] like that to
calm my sister down the thing was I
didn't but her friend did Oh No we
started dating and after around two
weeks I realized that I [ __ ] hated
this girl she is generally stupid as
[ __ ] yeah dude this is all good this is
all good stuff because you're learning
lessons what you're supposed to in life
especially at 18 okay this whole thing
started with a lie okay and that you did
to protect your sisters feelings so you
just got to come clean
you got to dump the dummy and just tell
her like listen I love you so much that
I actually started dating somebody that
is [ __ ] stupid all right I'm sorry
you have then then she'll get mad that
you'll be like he's calling her friends
stupid are you saying my friends are
stupid no I'm saying that friend that is
a friend of you is stupid the other ones
seem really smart and you know tell all
of them I wouldn't mind if they faked
six and came home and hooked up with me
all right
I realized that I [ __ ] eighty this
girl she's generally stupid as [ __ ] my
original plan was
pretend I was into her for a few months
and then when I go to university
in a few months I'd break up with her
because of the long distance dude don't
do that because you might break her
heart all right but that's some dumb
[ __ ] you do when you're 18 that way I'd
save my relationship with my sister and
and mother and get rid of this stupid
[ __ ] hey hey hey hey hey they'll talk
about women you don't need to talk about
them like that okay feel lucky that you
know you got a better brain than she did
yeah no don't play with people's
feelings like that all right because I'm
telling you right now that you that if
you're any sort of an actual human being
breaking somebody's heart the guilt of
that never [ __ ] goes away however I
recently received news that my first
choice University turned me down and my
second choice was the only one that
accepted me the problem is she lives 15
minutes away from my second choice
University and now I don't know what to
do you got to come clean I can't go
through university hitched to a girl I
[ __ ] hate but I can't afford to risk
my relationship with my family for
obvious reasons also another girl who I
think I generally may have a connection
with recently broke up with her
boyfriend in two years and I'm pretty
sure that if I could if I could we would
be dating right now it also doesn't help
that this girl is a nine out of ten
looking model and I'm probably a six and
a half out of ten at best thanks for
your help you freckled one all right
dude this is what you got to learn
you're gonna learn honesty here all
right [ __ ] break up with that woman
today all right and you have to come
clean with everybody in your house and
you have to say you know you have to put
your foot down that your parents cannot
be choosing oh maybe I would have this
conversation with your parents they
can't be choosing your sister over you
straight across the board because of
your sister's depression and anxiety
issues okay I don't know how severe they
are all right if they're chemical then
yeah that's a major
but you know if she just needs to
[ __ ] you know get out of a funk then
I don't know I don't know where she is
on the whole depression spectrum if
that's the proper thing but like you
shouldn't have to be suffering like this
dude you gotta live your own [ __ ]
life all right
just live your life live your life when
you live your life sometimes people are
gonna get hurt all right [ __ ] that
breakup with this woman and go ask the
other woman out that's it that's what
the [ __ ] you do and if anybody in your
family has a problem with it let him
vent to you and all that stuff and just
say I'm sorry that I am doing what my
heart is telling me to do all right I am
NOT trying to hurt anybody in this
family had I known that hooking up with
that girl was gonna cause this level of
drama I wouldn't have done it I regret
that I did it
I actually felt so bad that I actually
[ __ ] dated her for two weeks
the whole time and it was like talking
to a [ __ ] chair say all this stuff
nicely all right
there's a woman that I like that I want
to pursue and I'm gonna do that and if
that's wrong that god damn it I don't
want to be right and walk out okay and
don't let them hold your sister's
[ __ ] problems over your goddamn head
because that's good look what it's
already doing it's causing you to
[ __ ] date people you don't want a
date so then she's gonna be depressed
and you're gonna be living this life of
[ __ ] misery because you didn't do
what you wanted okay
now having said that don't call women
[ __ ]
all right don't do that I'm not saying
don't call them out on their [ __ ] and
stand your ground but they don't don't
ever do the name-calling thing all right
because it doesn't get you it not only
does it makes the other person not hear
what your point is then they can bring
that up for the rest of your [ __ ]
relationship and God knows they're gonna
do it all right that's the [ __ ]
podcast [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in on
you
on Thursday buh-bye